[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
brilliant guests this week is a former
banker policy advisor turned comedian
Yushan Akbar welcome to trigonometry
hello nice to be here it's great to have
you man thanks for coming on thank me
listen the first question we always ask
people when they bring when we bring
them on the show is how are you where
you are what's been your journey through
life how did you come to the point that
they you're at now what immediately it
was by train for the whole thing you're
not the first person that's done you're
the first comedian that's done that we
was done by economists before you yeah
and I read economics University say this
is consistent made to behavior I guess
yeah I where do I begin I was born in
Whitechapel in East London with my
family called at Brown mosque you're
welcome we my mum came from a very
wealthy Bangladeshi family my granddad
actually helped write the constitution
of Bangladesh you made it a secular
Constitution making Bangladesh the only
muslim-majority country which has a
secular Constitution so you can thank my
granddad for that but my dad came from
the other side of the tracks Pakistani
immigrant you know had to make his way
through life so her parents weren't
happy by that I imagine her parents will
help this was my mom second marriage and
my mom quite controversial for a Muslim
woman to get a divorce at that time it
was relatively controversial bet because
my granddad was he was quite woke for
his time he kind of understood the
circumstances behind why would that
happen my mom and I'm writing a novel
about the whole thing actually say that
might come up later but as to why that
happened
case and why that's important to know is
because that then had a big impact on my
upbringing my mum was a staunch
Thatcherite and my dad was a trade union
labor right so I grew up with these two
opposing views in the house both
identified as Muslim and gave me for
LaHood's purposes quite a decent Muslim
upbringing although my mum went to a
Roman Catholic private school Emanuel Ax
so when I was six and I was beginning to
show kind of signs of I want to say
radicalization but basically I didn't
have I had a few choice words about
Jewish people at six years old right no
what I was saying goes - no but you know
you just motivated by the truth he said
it not me but this is passing the views
I might have had a Mott in Moscow
amongst my friends and it was my mom who
basically well first she beat me up when
she heard it and then she explained to
me that you know it was a lottery of
life that meant I was born into a Muslim
family if I was born a Jewish family a
Christian family I'd be saying that
they're the best religions and whatever
else so only because of my mom I had a
bit of a liberal attitude towards faith
anyway then I went to a church of
england private school became the first
muslim choirboy which is just if there
was a whole mess of stuff going on i was
the poorest fattest kid at the school i
was there an academic scholarship I was
a complete misfit and then with the
other Muslim boys who were there I think
was about four or five of them Here I am
singing hymns about Jesus being Lord and
so it was I was just a constant
confusion to everyone all that said and
done during that time I out them on to
university I was at university I was a
part-time bollywood dance choreographer
[Laughter]
and when I call it choreography we just
waking up every day just dancing random
people follow me behind and after I
graduated I joined a bank and was a
private banker so I did wealth
management for celebrities the 2008
financial crisis I was very easily
expendable so was made redundant and did
a masters in global governance and
public policy worked in government for a
bit where they sent me out to local
authorities to give policy advice that
was good that was good it was good
actually was that it was at a time just
around the coalition and we did the
census in 2011 and that was when there
was a lot of stuff and my greatest
achievement in that job was getting a
conservative MP to defect to you Kip
douglas Carswell no Suzanne Evans oh
really
well she was I didn't don't you remember
she was a concern yeah sorry
and at the time we were at Madison
Council and she was upset about the
number of white people being reduced to
Merton and she thought this was like
some sort of conspiracy by ethnic
minority people to get rid of white
people and all it was this is white
people had more money and moved in -
sorry and also as well nobody wants to
live in Morden so that and then during
that time I started running for a few
newspapers all right some opinion pieces
with the Guardian and The Times started
working in a few different places had my
sights set on becoming the broadcast
journalist the producer of the Cheryl
said you're quite funny to try stand-up
that was four years ago started doing
stand-up
a year later I joined HSBC as a
speechwriter to CEO encom's advisor and
then a year after that quit to do comedy
full-time now you're here now I'm here
doing trigonometry made it yes exactly
so I'm just curious religious in terms
of religion it sounds like I mean I I
don't want a stereotype but I when I
think of Islam I don't think of the most
liberal kind of upbringing and what
you're talking about where your mom
taught you seems to like a very liberal
thing right so it was for me so hey I
think for me what was difficult growing
up was I was given a very little
view what Islam is but then I was
surrounded by people who didn't share
the same kind of views so for example
one of my mom's closest friends growing
up was a gay hairdresser who I remember
very distinctly in 1988 first time I met
my dad and he he had his sight sets on
my dad basically it was very funny
seeing him kind of sat next to my dad
and my dad kind of edging away I don't
have to deal with this and my mom just
cracking up this is the funniest thing
I've ever seen
but then when I would go to mosque from
my Quranic teaching the things they'd
say about gay people the things they'd
say about the West and that's it you
know and certainly after 9/11 there was
a real shift to the right as I'd call it
within within the mosque which alienated
me a bit more and it was curious to me
because even my friends on my dad's side
of the family as well they've got some
very choice things to say about what we
would continue to be quite liberal
topics LGBT community and all this kind
of stuff even Jews whatever it might be
and they're quite vocal about their
displeasure with many things Israel
comes up and you can when imagine what
views are in most places about the
existence of Israel and so for me
growing up it was very difficult
reconciling what I believed to be my
community when I was outside of the
house to the stuff my parents were
saying to me you know my parents would
pray and they would identify themselves
as Muslim you know my mom who passed
away four years ago she was buried a
Muslim was given a Muslim burial and my
dad was still identify as a Muslim he
doesn't drink he doesn't eat bacon or
any of that kind of stuff I don't see
him pray but when he does get in the car
he'll say a little prayer before he sets
off and Karen and flight say car or any
kind of traveling I see my dad doing a
little prayer but that was difficult we
say I was a misfit in in the mosque as
why even when I led the court of prayer
in the mosque
I did it and at the time I believed in
in the goodness of it and the intention
behind it but actually my version of
Islam that I grew up with isn't the
version of Islam that I think we see in
the UK and I have a theory as to why
this might be the case and I think it's
to do with the socioeconomic status of
migrants who come to the UK and bring a
conservative brand of that faith with
them because most liberal attitudes in
almost any faith group particularly in
Islam tended to be when the upper
echelons of their society so the
Ottomans would rule a Muslim empire but
actually would drink and have concubines
and all this kind of stuff and even
there's evidence to suggest that you
know during the Islamic enlightenment
which most people regard as being
between the eighth and the 14th
centuries it's quite a long time in
terms of scientific advances and social
advances led the world in medicine yeah
yeah all that kind of stuff and you know
when Islam came to be its did this
audacious thing of giving women rights
through an inheritance and allowing
women to excuse me divorce their
husbands and all this kind of stuff so
it was quite progressive but the people
who were able to exercise those
progressive behaviors tended to be in
the upper echelon of society and the
ones who couldn't tend to be the lower
and most migration if you see anywhere
tends to come from people who are from
lower socioeconomic groups that's why
they move there's layers of my family
members who just haven't left Bangladesh
because they've got 15 servants and
they're just to be able to afford
property it's interesting when you talk
about actually I was gonna ask you do
you think it's also to do with the fact
that if you're a minority you have to
work that much harder to kind of
preserve your identity I see it with the
Russian community in this country
loads of people who are not religious
will go to church because it gives them
a place where they can come to and be in
a community and as a result of that they
kind of becomes not you wouldn't say
they're religious but they're they're
you know what they kind of get into that
yeah I think I think absolutely has a
big part to play because obviously the
mosque is gonna be the place where you
get advice about stuff about how to
survive in this country and all this and
by osmosis you'll pick up some views but
also and this is something I found
having gone to being a brown kid in
private school having worked with doing
my banking days people at the very top
end of British society to survive you
have to sometimes not necessarily agree
with but allow certain views to be
expressed and over time my feeling is
that people hear those views you might
not necessarily believe them but it's
much easier to be like yeah I hate gays
- even if you might not and a child or a
nephew or someone might hear you saying
that and they're like okay that's what
I'm supposed to do and those views just
tend to permeate permeate so I think
there's absolutely some something in the
fact that people have to stay close to
their communities and how big a problem
do you think these types of views are
within the faith do you think they're a
major problem or is it just a small
subset of people or is it widely
prevalent and it's a very difficult it's
difficult question I think the first
thing to say is it there is difficult to
say answer that properly is because to
refer to Islam as one thing is actually
quite complicated it
I don't think calling Islam Islam is
helpful because there are so many sects
within Islam more so than almost any
other I think because the formation of
Islam was in a part of the world where
there were so many tribes and the reason
why when people say Islam means peace is
because the word literally does
translate to peace and the reason it
translates to pieces because when the
Prophet Muhammad is said to have
received his revelation his whole
intention was to encourage peace in the
Arabian Peninsula so there's 12 months
in the Arabic calendar three of which
are just about truce one of them being
Ramadan where the idea is just don't
fight and a central theme of the Prophet
Muhammad idea ideology was something
called the umma which means community
and the umma included Christians Jews
pagans all this kind of stuff and this
in the 7th century but now
if you speak to people in our some of
the young Maria's they'll say just
Muslim and so for that reason it becomes
problematic to be able to give one
homogeneous view of what I think Islam
or people who identify as Muslim would
say however that said I am willing to go
out on a limb and say that in a generic
view across all those tribes and people
who identify themselves within the
umbrella of Islam they probably don't
like the LGBT community didn't approve
of it and that is I think problematic
for me it's problematic certainly
because what come out I identify Island
fires 86% straight I'm just like how
many hammering moment does one have to
kiss before they identify as gay you've
got a try I believe this I believe I
mean this isn't Angie you've got less
than eight I won't say the number but
more less than eight and more than two
you've got Troy disgust me look it's
very monochrome colors dismissed nothing
from the rainbow there we did get a
psychologist on very prominent notable
psychologists and she was talking to me
and directing her attention to me and I
thought all right she really likes me
no it wasn't she just thought
Constantine was gay a psychologist
thanks that yeah okay
but you know it back to your point the
question you are saying is that you you
were talking about how people yeah yeah
and I think that that's probably fair to
say I think I saw those surveys there
were surveys of British Muslims and I
think
more than 50% of British Muslims say
that homosexuality should be legal oh it
doesn't surprise me at all
yeah because it's curious to me because
a lot of Muslim friends I have a big
part of their humor growing up that I've
seen earn on the side of photo
homosexuality yeah so and I guess we're
now in a place where faux homosexuality
probably isn't that funny anymore
because that you know when we were kids
we smile that's gay there's gay that's
um whatever but I certainly remember a
time growing up we're kind of made to
free speech podcast so so basically you
know my Muslim friends would be like are
you Cara like that I want to [ __ ] you ha
hilarious but then they are so V many
opposed to the idea of someone literally
doing that and I remember when I was 12
years old my you're gonna like this
story so well as 12 years old my sunny
side of the family there's a few cousins
I have heel kind of emcees and rappers
and I don't want to shock you but
emceeing rapping is something I'm a
regular we wear into the house my
cousins were rapping and they said his
Sean why don't you wrap to the beat now
I didn't have any raps what I did have
was my school song which is fluent
lassen yeah so to the beat I dropped in
pictorial board they stopped and they
said to me what are you gay what's wrong
with you are you gay and I remember it
12 saying well what's wrong with being
gay
oh boy the family got involved uncles
we're calling my dad saying your son's
gay
this is unbelievable let's get to the
mosque the imam to sort him out Oh baby
but I saw firsthand just how angry that
particular idea became I saw firsthand
after 9/11 how angry people are about
the idea of the West whilst espouse
those views in the West and I always
found that bit curious as well being
like hold on you're telling me all this
stuff in English in a mosque in East
London having just driven your BMW here
complaining about how [ __ ] the West is
and Western foreign policy and this that
and the other your tax is going to fund
those wars which is an unfortunate
reality for all of us if it matters to
you that much go over there and sort it
out but people wouldn't like me saying
that it's exactly the same with Russians
it's exactly the same I know so many
people in the Russian community in this
country who go on and on about how
terrible Britain is and I'm like well
why don't you [ __ ] off back to Russia
that's what I mean this is yeah that's
the most British thing in the world
isn't it just to moan about something
yeah I do get that but they're not
coming from a British it's like we had
it all great in the Soviet Union I'm
like well why are you here then yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot of that stuff
that's happened and look I'm not saying
that you can't criticise of course you
can yeah but for me it seems to me that
certainly the the Muslims that I tend to
interact with in the Muslims that I know
their criticisms seem to be completely
at odds with everything it takes to
exist in a liberal-minded Western
society and that to me is where they
becomes a problem because when people
say to me Islam is incompatible with
living in the West I end up sitting
there thinking well I can see why people
would say that I can see why people say
that
by the same token I don't think you need
a real liberalism if people want to
identify that way is to accept that
people are gonna be different is to
accept that they'll be Muslims who won't
drink and for them not to be chastised
for that but they are is to accept that
wait hold on are they yeah no I'm just I
don't know I don't drink and and ever
since I gave I gave up drinking 2011
it's has been the single most well there
you go these trials come out as gay
Francisco
I've got to come out with something now
myself ya know but the reason I wasn't
challenging okay the assumption I was
asking would Muslims be chastised for
not drinking yeah you know because I
think one common refrain that's made
about this is that they don't integrate
and when you ask someone what does that
mean they'll say they stick to their own
and they can challenge that and say well
everyone stick to their own you know the
chipping norton people are sticking to
their own dx2 people you're going to see
today are sticking to their own they say
well okay they don't really come to us
and as you probe in you Pro many pro but
that basically means is there are some
cultural things that we do in the UK
that the Muslim community just aren't
privy to just on part a part of and I
personally think that's fine you know if
you don't want to drink don't drink and
put we can talk about alcohol another
time I think alcohol is a ridiculous
thing to be legal moreso than marijuana
but anyway yeah let's talk about that
later on yeah but nevertheless it's it's
curious to me that there are so many
views within Muslim households that are
fundamentally at odds with so much about
what we would consider to be Western
liberal values in particular I imagine
the attitude is it the attitude to women
you're alluding to here as well i partly
although i think that's changing yeah
but also the women thing is an
interesting one because i i don't want
to necessarily align a lot of the
applications of what the Quran teaches
about women to an Islamic application
necessarily because a lot of Muslim
households across the world tend to have
quite matriarchal paradigms right so
women rule the roost in the house women
rule the roost in some communities but
it is I would argue this historical
patriarchal attitude that has meant that
women have been subjugated consistently
and in a way that to you and I in the
West would seem
quite regressive in those particular
communities laying there Saudi Arabia
making making making the effort to give
women the right to drive which is a risk
they're willing to take well they don't
anymore
are they yeah
probably still the actuaries probably
make sure that women anyway but yeah
some some attitudes to women attitude to
the LGBT community attitudes to certain
Western ideologies or Western foreign
policy all of that staff in some
sometimes makes me think well I can see
why people would say you're incompatible
because compatibility in essentially in
the UK now there are more halal
restaurants there are more halal desert
desert bars and all this kind of stuff
great wonderful to have that provision
that's not also that's not necessarily
you're still doing it within your own
community when you go to parts of Burma
or Manchester it's just you know see a
sea of brown faces on one Street and
that's fine that's just how communities
are formed but if you're in places like
Exeter or as I was yesterday Royal
Tunbridge Wells and you open the paper
and that's what you see
you're gonna think to yourself well they
don't want to be a part of us and
actually to be fair if you ask them no
probably say we don't want to be a part
with them and if they're here we might
have to be forced to be to associate
with them and we don't want that and
that's where these kind of schisms come
I think what I wanted to do is just
drill down a little bit where do you
think the
intolerance the LBGT people comes from
LGBT yeah LGBT LGBTQI I mean because
because I went to I went to Catholic
school so you know there's some passages
in the Bible you know that's some
extreme Christians use in order to
justify their intolerance but where does
it come from within is it in the Quran
itself is it explicit within the crowd
yeah yeah it is explicit in the Quran
about homosexuality being a sin and the
Quran also is quite progressive in their
displeasure with the homosexual
community because it also specifically
talks about the same sex which the Bible
and the Quran doesn't cause it when he
talks about gays it just assumes men yes
so that's interesting and I think it
comes from the same place it's just it's
just fear isn't it's just this idea that
you know populations have to increase
and the populations to increase you need
heterosexual relationships and
homosexual relationships are a barrier
to that increase and particularly when
you're a religion like Islam which is
born in the middle of warfare so you
were very already quite isolated and the
only way to expand or protect yourself
is to have an expansive population
homosexuality is a complete barrier to
that I don't personally think that there
is there's more of a dislike for
homosexuality from that perspective as
opposed to an inherent idea of it just
being wrong because and this and perhaps
my liberal mindedness all of us I think
growing up have some sort of challenge
with our sexuality we I don't think
there's anything is your 100% straight
straight out of the womb you can't
possibly know there are moments loop as
a kid six seven when you don't know
anything you might see a bloke a Beulah
oh he's good-looking oh I'm feeling
things like that you know whatever so I
think we're
be ridiculous to suggest that there's
nobody in the Muslim community in the
seventh or eighth centuries who weren't
gay and it's because there were enough
gay people for that to be a revelation
that God felt was necessary to put to
the Prophet Muhammad there must've been
enough Gable for that to have happened
you said I mean time so if there are
enough gay people in the seventh century
there must have been enough gate
potentially potentially gay people
within the Muslim community and then for
them to be told by Imams don't be gay
because if you are the big man in the
sky ain't gonna be happy about it
well this one's gonna say this is like
you talk about Islam but Orthodox
Christianity the people who really
genuinely follow it and believe it it's
the same well this is all everything
you've said so far applies equally to
them yeah the hatred of Jews the
subjugation of women the you know I I
know a very religious guy in in in
Eastern Europe who I have to see
regularly who said to me that all gay
people are pedophiles right okay
in his defense he is a priest but yeah
so this what I'm saying is it's I don't
think this is exclusive to Islam at all
ya know what I get the sense of is any
religion whose adherents are really
really deeply committed to it will
typically go much further in those
things than a religion that's maybe
become more liberalized like you know
Anglicism or something like that you
know what I mean yeah and I've been
thinking about this which is you know
Islam the year in Islam is what from now
[Music]
1448 I think something like that she's
younger religious yes it's a younger
religion is still quite new that said
you know if you've had six centuries of
enlightenment where you've really helped
Society global society move forward I
don't see why they should shouldn't be
liberal or being a slightly softer on on
particular these kind of issues why
Christianity
has been able to get to a point where
gay people can go into church and pray
and I mean that said I don't think a gay
person can necessarily go into Church
and be like hi guys I'm gay I'm about to
pray really clever because I don't I
think people do want to hold that part
their identity close to them when they
go to a place of religious worship
I think Islam is a long way away from
accepting openly that gay or transgender
people will come into the mosque and one
or two liberal mosques are opening up
like you know and this will give you an
example of where these attitudes prevail
about a month ago I received a message
from a family friend of mine who is he's
a dentist
he married he's got a daughter so on the
face of it you know an intelligent bloke
you know intelligent late he sent us
sent me a message with a picture of this
liberal muscle development Germany this
allows transgendered and gay people to
pray and his only quote - it was a sign
of the end of times and I was like well
why do you think that that's a sign of
the end of time sure that's a sign of
progress a sign at the beginning it and
he said this isn't worse arms about
there is there is no way that this would
work and I said okay what was your
daughter decided to be transgender you
know what she felt that she was trying
to think oh that's not my daughter then
and this is a guy who was born and
raised in England is my age it's a
dentist and so obviously surround
himself and we'll see people who are
from different communities and has those
views yeah and I said to him well if
that's the case what you need to be
doing it every time a customer a patient
comes in find out their sexuality if
they're gay don't accept their money
because you can't you can't do both you
can't say I don't think you're allowed
to be gay but also I'll take the hundred
fifty pounds or a crown that doesn't
make any sense to me and he's a good
example in he and millions of others
like him exist they are born in the 80s
in the UK have caught
it been here in this wave of liberalism
that we've seen and yet are very
steadfast in their views about things
like this but do you think the reason
for that is fundamentally religion is
illogical its faith-based you were asked
to believe in something that there is no
truth for ya so therefore people's
belief systems aren't founded in logic
because it's illogical I you're
absolutely right and that's my feeling
as well but a lot of Muslims will turn
around and say Islam is the most logical
of all the faiths and their defense for
this is to say that so Islam beyond the
actual revelation doesn't have any
miracles
everything that happens you know the
Prophet Mohammed is a 40 year old bloke
he married someone who's near 1516 years
older than him went through a couple of
our he's just a normal guy who had this
revelation all the miracles that exist
in the Quran were in the older books the
Bible in the Torah because of the
Islamic enlightenment algebra
mathematics hospitals all this kind of
stuff they will say to what Islam is
very logical because it's LOM is such a
way of life the five times a day all
this stuff they will find a logical
reason for those rules to exist but I
think you're absolutely right that
ultimately you have to have faith that
praying five times a day is a logical
thing to do in when you're living in the
UK and you have to work from out the
hours of nine till five if you if that's
how your life has panned out and are
eating yeah for Ramadan you know that
it's and they'll say to you okay
it might be hard for us but you know
they had to do it in the desert you know
in the sixth and seventh and eighth
centuries and we'll my argument is more
than the sixth and seventh and eighth
centuries they didn't have jobs they
weren't sat in front of a computer and
that didn't have James birthday turning
up with a cake but you know all this
kind of stuff but yeah that they
absolutely have faith and often there's
no reason to that
[Music]
so let me ask you this question this is
gonna be this difficult question to ask
and I don't particularly want to ask you
but I feel like you're going to you by
I'm going to because I think it's
important see you later guys
you know how during the breaks our
referendum there was this whole thing
every time you could be accused of being
racist Nigel Farage would come out and
he'd be like we are the only party who's
got who are who've said publicly we're a
non racist party and everybody would
look at that and gobble that means
you're probably racist yeah I mean you
know you know where every time there's a
terrorist attack and everyone comes out
and goes lamb is a religion of peace
yeah I kind of feel it's a bit like
there is a sense in me that you wouldn't
constantly be saying it if there wasn't
some kind of issue there do you know
what I mean oh okay that's a good
question it's actually a good question I
think part of the reason why a lot of
Muslims and the Muslim community feel
the need to do that when a terrorist
attack happens is because the Muslim
community is roundly criticized when a
terrorist attack happens you know and I
like we did these you aligned if I get a
thank you but you know what I'm saying
like I personally get I don't think that
Islam is particularly any different any
other religion maybe it's a younger
religion maybe people are more devout
and because of that they're maybe
because it was born of war as you say
there is a more militaristic element but
but it's just that the way we talk about
it's almost like you can't point out
that people of a certain religion do
keep committing terrorist attacks you
know what I mean yeah and the thing is
is it's fair to say I talk about this in
my show yeah we you should have made
that clear because otherwise it just
looks like we got a brown for no reason
you talk about religion
[Laughter]
myah D'Ambrosio profit like it's hot
which I'm doing at the Soho Theatre
great thank you very much I take the
copy of the Koran the stage and I talk
about what the quran' says about certain
things and one of the things i talk
about is terrorism and you know there is
a very clear distinct passage in the
quran which says that you must with the
might of the pen or the sword basically
get rid of infidels and you know this is
a 7th century text born of war that
required strength in numbers and if
there are people who you know people who
don't support your ideology when you're
in a small village one person is
dangerous
because they could get the attention of
another village here from another tribe
and they'll come and kill your whole
village okay so for that time it
actually makes sense to me it makes
sense that you'd want to protect your
own as barbaric as it seems we're here
in the 21st of you the seventh century
life was completed everybody was like
that everybody was like that so you know
like you need to do this now it's fair
to say that a lot of the terrorist
attacks that we hear about the majority
of which majority of them have an
islamic element to them i get really
angry when a terrorist attack happens
and people come out and say this has
nothing to do with islam but you don't
want to hold in a minute they're not
reading the bible they are Muslim
followers even if they are extreme
right-wing followers there are still
extreme right-wing followers of Islam
and they are conducting these attacks
people then wanting to defend themselves
and say look we're not part of this
harks back to the point that I made
earlier about Islam being so big and the
spectrum being so wide that what the
Taliban do and what al Qaeda do and what
our Shabaab do Boko Haram all these
people what they do of course you don't
want to align yourself with because that
is an extreme view but I will say this
if you were to probe enough Muslims and
and I did this with the you Kipp
manifesto actually three years ago I
took a copy that you kept manifesto on
stage didn't announce it was read out
some of their manifesto pledges and said
give me a favor this could beat you
you'd be amazed at how many things
people agreed with people don't want to
pay hospital parking charges
you keep said we don't want people to
pay hospital parking chance and that
kind of stuff but if you took certain
elements of say the Boko Haram manifesto
and took it to Muslims and asked them
some of the questions that you and all
you and I might find a bit Oh for
example we don't think the State of
Israel should exist or we think
homosexuality is a sin I would argue
that there would be enough Muslims
who would agree with their statements
and that's where there becomes a problem
I'm by no means a jesting that any
Muslim that I certainly know or grown up
with would condone any kind of terrorist
attack well I think they would condone
or agree with is the underlying reasons
why that attack may have occurred that
Western foreign policy is killing
Muslims every single day which may well
be true that Islamophobia is so rife
that attack is the best form of Defense
sir those kind of sentiment you said I
mean so those kind of sentiments may
well be not entirely uncomfortable to a
lot of Muslims who are the ones to say
Islam is a religion of peace because as
much as it is a religion of peace that
suggests that if Islam was a religion of
peace the opposite must be true
that there was enough whatever the
opposite pieces strife violence that
there was enough of the opposite for you
to have to have peace in the first place
do you sort of mean yeah yeah and so to
your point I don't think it's because
they
they believe will agree with the idea of
terrorism but I do think that a lot of
it is them feeding one feeling attacked
because look there are millions
immersion has got nothing to do with why
Isis and all these people I realized
that when I listed out the terrorist
organizations actually mentioned Isis at
all yeah the first one mentioned them
there's so many that's right the fact
that there are so many Muslim based
terrorist organizations Harkes are the
point that actually you can't homogenize
this group because there are Bukka Haram
people who look at how about people and
think they're pansies know there was a
point that I think a couple of years ago
or something the Taliban had to distance
themselves from Isis yeah do you
remember to say this is extreme what
Isis are doing here extreme you're like
what this is insane but also heard that
when Isis were around in Levant and Iraq
the bins were always collected Isis had
one it's like the whole it made the
trains run yeah yeah no but your bins
out you know it's interesting to me just
how familiar all of us all the sounds to
Russians and Russia because Russians say
the same [ __ ] about Stalin Stalin well
yeah I mean he killed 50 million people
but but there was order yeah there was
order you know and in terms of the
religion as well like the you know maybe
you remember the Charlie Hebdo attacks
right yeah yeah yeah that same priest
that I was telling you about he was
actually defending the Muslims who
attacked them he said they shouldn't be
making fun of religion and anyone who
makes fun of religion should be killed
well there you go and it's not just
Islam so I'm definitely yeah
it is absolutely look I've spoken to
Muslim comedians and asked them if
because of my show were at the Quran
onstage if someone was to hurt me nay
kill me do you think they'd be justified
in that attack
in doing that to me their non-response
was telling Wow comedians these comedic
Muslim comedians essentially understand
why someone would hurt you yeah
now that mother was taking a book on
stage yeah
now those Muslim comedians they by no
mean condone the act of killing or me
being hurt yeah but what they do
understand and sympathize with is the
reasons why someone might be they see
where they're coming from yesterday and
how much this is to do with the invasion
of Afghanistan and Iraq and everything
that happened post 9/11 I'm about to say
something that I think it's gonna get me
in a lot of trouble but yeah but also I
wouldn't be me if I didn't I think
certainly you and I lesser I know less
how about you but sending you and I I
think it's fair to say that where we
observe that oppression or voicing your
sense of oppression is sexy feeling
oppressed and voicing that is sexy there
is a strand within the Muslim community
which I described as the Yasser Arafat
scarf wearing sexy group of Muslims
where you talk about Israel you talk
about Palestine you talk about Iraq you
talk about Afghanistan you talk about
Western foreign policy and you talk
about homophobia and that group exists
they're not entirely wrong but there are
very vocal minority of people who in a
sense operate in a way that wouldn't be
in my mind too dissimilar from any other
kind of extreme group in the sense that
we're costly under the FAC we are
justified in feeling this stuff because
we're constantly oppressed
we're justified in cleaning this because
I can't go through an airport without
getting checked I'm just trying to
feeling this because I can't
job because my name is Muhammad Allah
Loki I don't deny that those issues
exist my surname is Akbar
I've had enough problems you know I've
gone through airports nice and easily
and I'm also not gone through airports
nice and easily I've missed connecting
flights because I'm being checked out
I've also got two places earlier than I
should have done but if the
iraq-afghanistan thing is terrible but
I'd argue we don't talk about the plight
of the range of Muslims in as much
veracity as we do about Iraq and
Afghanistan that may be because we are
Western British Muslims who are in this
country and therefore able to criticize
the actions of our government more so
than the actions of the Burmese
government there are some people who are
talking about the plight of the Hyuga
Muslims in China who are in internment
camps but again I don't see or think
Isis are flying off to Beijing right I
don't see Isis or Al Shabaab it's a
shorter flight to Burma than it is to
the UK or America and that to me is
curious that why if those issues Iraq
and Afghanistan are bigger than any
other first of all why should they be
all Muslims around the world who are
being subjugated should have there
should be equality a a Far East Asian or
Burmese Muslim should nobody should not
be any lesser Muslim than an Iraqi or
and I've known a Sonny Muslim but to me
there seems to be like there's this
hierarchy that exists that we feel more
pained about the plight of them they
might again the argument might come back
well you can't you know be sad about
every single thing that goes and you've
got to pick on the issues you know
ultimately what happens in Iraq and
Afghanistan has galvanized this anti
Muslim attitude that has now prevailed
and gone to the Far East that might be a
defense that they'd give me to which I'd
say our call [ __ ] on that because
what the Chinese the Chinese don't give
a toss about what the Americans are
doing they just don't want you good
Muslims in their country and they're
gonna put them in camps and they're
gonna try and brainwash them out in
there this is happening when I watch
it's a horrible thing but I don't see
the yes Arafat scarf wearer complaining
about that nearly as much as he might be
about her accomplice thought and then
you'll say you know were seen from
Bradford who wants to do a tube attack
it's justified in doing so good he's so
sad about what's happening in Iraq and
Afghanistan and to me I'm like well
that's 15 years ago
what's the [ __ ] that we're dealing with
mil and also it's ignoring history
because bin Laden was funded by the CIA
to fight my ancestors right yeah he did
9/11 yeah you're basically biting
apparently yeah yeah not far away yeah
grew up in Sweden well make of that what
you will so yeah I think that's there's
there's a kind of ignorance of history
there as well there is no history and
also it of course I get that you can't
it's we can't possibly as human beings
be expected to contextualize absolutely
everything when it comes to things that
hurt us and upset us what we did what
the British did in Iraq and Afghanistan
and Libya for that matter and continues
to do in Syria is awful and moronic to
moronic stupid all four and it pains me
that my tax which I'm doing doing the
return soon that my tax money goes to
that happening but at the same time
there is so much historical context
within Syria for example that there was
absolutely reason to believe
Bashar al-assad is killing his own
people there's reason to believe that
Colonel Gaddafi who is one of my top
three favorite dictators by the way that
Gaddafi wasn't the greatest to a large
swathe of the Libyan population and to
me the white man cannot possibly just
dominate all the oppression as well
Hitler can't be the worst dictator of
all you know brown Muslim people can
also be terrible to their own people and
we should be able to criticize and be
angry with them in the same kind of way
but I just don't think I haven't seen
evidence to suggest that people that I
know are as angry in their need for some
sort of punishment for Bashar al-assad
as they offer Tony Blair because it
still parts out sexy parlous and sexy
rhetoric around being this oppressed
Muslim guy who wears a scarf and is
constantly I can't even grow a beard
anymore because I'm a brown guy and all
this stuff which I find it difficult to
reconcile
I finally got difficult anyway we've got
about ten minutes left let's talk about
you you brought up the idea of
oppression and kind of where yeah and
it's not something that you and I've
really discussed too much in the past
but I'm just curious what you make of
the modern conversation about the point
that we've come to where I certainly
feel like essentially we're judging each
other by the colour Ruskin and agenda
and our sexuality all the time now I
mean yeah I think that's fair to say I
think now more than ever I feel like
I've got to get a flagpole and say what
this is my identity it's this it's this
it's this and it's exhausting and I just
think that because people have I think
part part of it is actually to do with
the loss of community in the UK the loss
of community over the last 20 years
that people feel the need to align
themselves to something and they're
getting more and more convoluted and
more more complicated to me it's no bone
off my back if you want to identify as a
non-binary Muslim transient whatever
that's your thing I don't need to be
hammered with it all the time and also I
should be able to say hey do you know
what if I'm about to get down and dirty
with a woman and then I found out she
used to have a penis suddenly or I'm
about to get down out dirty with a woman
and suddenly I see a penis I've got to
rewire my brain and just because I've
got to that rewiring doesn't mean that
I'm some sort of transphobic freak do
you and I mean and what curious to me is
these attitudes of this
self-identification is a liberal one it
is a fundamentally Abril idea but those
very liberals criticize roundly anybody
who has an opposite view and to me I
don't understand what kind of liberalism
we live in now because for me liberalism
is say whatever the [ __ ] you want do
whatever the [ __ ] you want be whoever
the hell you want I'll accept it for it
but accept it doesn't mean I'm going to
embrace everything that's not what
acceptance is that's not what how
societies are formed in communities are
formed because what you know my let's
take parents parents of a gay person
those parents may disagree with the idea
of homosexuality fundamentally but
they'll accept that their son is gay and
that's to compete differently the dads
don't like my okay now my son's gay
guess I better be gay too
that's not what acceptance is right and
so it's the same idea that at the moment
we've got to this point where just
because somebody is trying to and
doesn't mean I have to kiss a man to
prove that I'm no longer
I'm not a homophobe yeah do you think
partly this whole thing with identity
and and I felt it a lot myself is that
if you've come from your second
generation immigrant you've got
apparently an immigrant or like maybe
your mother's from one place your
father's a man
you you've never really had an identity
when you're in this country because you
can nobody never truly identify it's
British
yeah oh you remember when I went to
Venezuela people go to me like juicy as
British - well you know what are you and
you always have that sort of conflict
within you do you think maybe that stems
from maybe but I don't know how many
second generation immigrants are
actually like coming out as gay or
transgender or whatever I don't know
I can't possibly comment on that I
completely hear you know I not only do I
have the complication of being a second
donation and we're going to South Asian
parents but South Asian parents one of
whom came from Pakistan one of them came
from Bangladesh to countries that in
1971 had a massive civil war that
resulted in Bangladesh being born so and
then I was raised in this country the
way I was in quite a middle-class way
sound the way I do so when I go to
Bangladesh will be speaking Bangla
fluently then like a start you're not
one of us you're British and when I'm
here you know just last you in Jordan
called a [ __ ] and that was one my dad no
but by guns and it's just like well I
don't know where I belong but actually I
can just choose where I feel like I
belong where I'm wherever I'm
comfortable and I think a lot of people
that's what they're doing is they're
saying I want to be I want to take
ownership of my own identity and that's
great but me going to an EDL meeting and
forcing them to say I'm British that's
not gonna work that's they're not gonna
be like aurilla okay alright just
because you say it I now agree with you
and by the way I'm not aligning the EDL
with her however so many caveats you
gotta think I'm just tired of caveat
yeah so we're not on stage no don't
bother caveat Inc if you want to make a
judgement about the kind of person I am
because so for this show called
hate in life and once I was doing it I
said hey now if you don't know for the
listeners it's basically audience submit
like little categories or words and
you've got to say why you hate them and
the topic I got was children with cancer
right and in the context of that
particular it's quite funny thing to
come up and I said I hate children with
cancer because they're the weakest of
all the children I [ __ ] off the
cardfight was quite funny and people
loved but of course people came up to us
of being like why you condoning
pedophilia what they really came at
hated life assure that specifically
wants peace yeah yeah comedians are
there to say that's gusting yes and that
was a line that was crossing like why
are you condoning pedophilia what kind
of person are you they made a value
judgment on me as a comedian by the way
saying something that and you would get
a reaction and would hopefully be funny
yeah to at least five people in the
audience the five degenerates in the
audience right but they made a judgment
on me and this is the thing as a
comedian I see a lot the at the moment
you voice anything that doesn't fit
within what I call this liberal tyranny
within this liberal paradigm you are
chastised and Al stood as a pariah yeah
a social pariah and that is not
liberalism yeah that is Stasi right-wing
Nazi thinking at its core but they would
argue otherwise they'd be like no well
no you're not accepting you hit the nail
on the head man it's liberal ideas being
enforced through extremely liberalism
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is
yeah and that's why we started the show
man because we've just we're like we
can't pretend to think what we don't
think anymore
yeah yeah we just can't yeah and that's
exactly what you said becoming price
exactly what's happening yeah yeah
exactly what's happening and it's gonna
happen to you now well we've got to do
the last question when we deliver it the
last question yeah absolutely man listen
the last question we always ask is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about though we should be
talking about can be absolutely anything
could be something in the context of
what we've been talking about okay don't
say your show cause we will plug what
what aren't we talking about that we as
a society
okay and I think the thing that we
aren't talking about enough as a society
that we should be talking about is the
impact of tech in shaping societies and
democracies around the world because the
advent of the internet is what led to
the growth I would argue of terrorist
organizations like Isis and al-qaeda
because they're able to galvanize these
people from parts around the world and
the fact that online is where
communities are formed the Twitterati
the liberal - and all this stuff those
pockets are gonna get stronger and
stronger and more acute over time and my
feeling is that there needs to be some
sort of global sort of agreement for how
society will be structured because for
example China having a closed Internet
yet being quite possibly the most
powerful nation on earth it's quite a
curious situation and as more as become
more and more dependent on online and
tech I think there could be some serious
ramifications for global society in our
structured excellent well it's on your
on Twitter at I wanted to add each
al-akbar
that people struggle to spell that so
you have to put in Michael Pak entire
I'm not [ __ ] say Michael Pak entire
[Laughter]
people yeah you your your show which is
brilliant is at the sofa Theatre in
London and it's 11th to the 13th of
February yes if they go and see it it's
absolutely brilliant and if you can't
catch that just check out Sean's website
and he's got all the dates of him doing
different gigs right yeah and he's very
very funny guys played my comedy club I
seen him many times he's really really
great so check him out follow him on
Twitter readers guard you know I don't
read it don't read The Guardian ever
because they can't
and as always subscribe to us on YouTube
and YouTube on iTunes so he said the one
already said it's iTunes if you could
leave us a review being sanely grateful
follow us at trigger pod on Twitter if
you put tap the or click on the little
bell key it will tell you when we've got
a new episodes being released and most
importantly if you could leave a review
on iTunes and if not just telling mate
spread the word hatred needs to flourish
that's it we'll see you again next week
see ya guys
[Music]